imagine we start a clock as a pitcher
releases the ball that starts this
propagation of complications that happen
in the brain that try and localize where
the ball is in space and where it's
going it tries to predict the balls
trajectory the ball is moving too fast
you've been attractive with your eyes a
moment to moment your eye is rushing
ahead to the point where you expect to
see the ball you don't know exactly
where it's gonna be but you're making
your best guess and you have a couple
hundred milliseconds at best to pick the
next position we're gonna put your eyes
so right in Midway you get one glance at
the ball that's your decision point
you better be planning your swing now if
you're gonna hope to hit the ball if
you're used to seeing a ball moving on a
certain speed the same ninety miles an
hour's your average experience is
sampled that prediction is gonna put you
where the ball would be if it's
traveling at that assumed speed you move
your eyes to right where the position of
the ball should be for 90 mile an hour
fastball but lo and behold this picture
has some extra gas and they pitched it
at 103 miles an hour
it left pitchers hand you look where it
should be it isn't there and from your
perspective it's almost as if it
disappeared poof it's gone